in high school but look before I start
I'd like to say something about the
debate we had last night and I I heard
and and I listened to and I respect
senator Harris but you know we all know
that 30 seconds to 60 seconds on the
campaign debate exchange can't do
justice to a lifetime
committed to civil rights I want to be
absolutely clear about my record of
position on racial justice including
busing I never never never ever opposed
voluntary busing and as a program that
Senator Harris participated in and it
made a difference in her life I did
support federal action to address root
cause in segregation our schools and our
communities including taking on the
banks and redlining and trying to change
the way in which neighborhoods were
segregated I've always been in favor of
using federal authority to overcome
state initiated segregation in fact I
cast the deciding vote in 1974 against
an amendment called the gurney amendment
which would have banned the right of the
federal courts to be able to use busing
as a remedy and you might guess in the
middle of the most extensive busing
order in American history in my city in
my state it wasn't what you called the
most popular vote in the country at the
time so Reverend Jackson we spent a lot
of time working together over the years
on a lot of issues that matter and I
know I know and you know I fought my
heart out to ensure that civil rights
and voting rights equal rights are
enforced everywhere these rights are not
are not up to the states to decide there
are federal government's duty to decide
it's a constitutional question to
protect the civil rights of every single
American and that's always been my
position and so that's why I ran for
federal office in the first place as
Reverend Jackson may be one of the few
people who knows my city was the only
city after dr. King was assassinated
that was almost burned to the ground 20%
of it the only city in the United States
America since reconstruction that was
occupied by the National Guard withdrawn
bayonets on almost every corner for ten
months
I came home from law school that year
and I only had two political heroes dr.
Kane and Bobby Kennedy and they were
both assassinated the year I graduated
and I came home well I had a job with a
very old one of the oldest law firms in
the state a prestigious firm and after
five months I decided I couldn't do it
and I ended up leaving and becoming a
public defender when I was elected one
of the first things I did is to go on a
committee to try to strengthen the
Voting Rights Act I co-sponsored Equal
Rights Amendment
I supported making the threat the equity
act in law and may make the law of the
land today I voted for the Civil Rights
Act of 1992 banned employment
discrimination
I wrote the law of the provision of the
law that allows the Attorney General to
pursue cases involving quote a pattern
or practice of conduct by law
enforcement officers in violation of
constitutional of federal rights
I wrote that law and I used that power
during the obama-biden administration in
our Department of Justice investigative
police discrimination and abuse
including Ferguson by the way we worked
like the devil to make sure that you
should not allow Police Department's to
by excess military vehicles like
up-armored Humvees and armored personnel
carrier you don't go into a neighborhood
and police going in and up armored
Humvee or a personnel carrier our
criminal justice forum reforms as
president vice-president reduced the
federal population by 38,000 people
ladies and gentlemen and the obama-biden
administration we commuted more
sentences than the president did then
the 13 previous presidents combined we
pass is supported by the way with all
due respect I say to Chicagoans and
everyone my president gets much too
little credit for all that he did he was
one of the great presidents of United
States of America and I'm tired of
hearing about what he didn't do
this man had a backbone like a ramrod a
backbone like a ram I do you want to
know what a man and woman's made of
watch them under incredible pressure he
got elected because we were about to
fall off a cliff we went out and we had
passed affordably we had to pass an act
that was Recovery Act 800 billion
dollars and guess what
remember he stood up on the he loved it
he loved to the State of the Union and
turn and surprise me he didn't tell him
he said in Sheriff Joe is going to
enforce the Act
thanks a lot mr. president 800 billion
dollars but we did it without less than
2% of waste fraud or abuse in that act
but here's what he did everything that
landed on his desk I watched him I
watched him I sat with him every single
morning and I watched him for hundreds
of hours in that in the in the so-called
what the situation was not where Wolf
Blitzer lives in the real situation I
watched it and I want to tell you
Chicago you had a great great man out
here and he's still a great man he still
has a lot to offer
we're in office we pass the supportive
disciplined addition to start to break
the school-to-prison pipeline folks the
discussion in this race today shouldn't
be about the past we should be talking
about how we can do better how we can
move forward how we can give every child
in America and the opportunity for
success stories
these aren't somebody else's children
they're our children they're all our
children not a joke they're all our
children and though the kite strings
that lift our national ambitions of loft
we have to make people realize what you
all are doing what you're doing is every
single child in America has enormous
potential every single child has
enormous potential but it means means
you have to have good schools in every
neighborhood no child's future should be
determined by the zip code that's why I
proposed tripling funding for title one
schools to eliminate disparities between
rich and poor school districts we're
going to increase teachers pay we're
gonna make we're gonna make pre-k
absolutely requirement across the board
ladies and gentlemen these teachers they
walk into school every day like my wife
she taught in the public school system
and now she teaches the community
college she's never stopped teaching by
the way she's the only second lady ever
know who's got a full-time job teaching
fifteen credits a semester
I don't know how by the way I'm known as
Jill Biden's husband I'm proud of that
but I earned it I had asked her five
times to marry me before she do it
anyway well look those are your teachers
in here you know you know you're
expected to teach kids to read write add
and subtract but guess what
kids come to school with the burdens and
problems we have too few psych school
psychologists we have too few social
workers we have too few people are in
there doing what needs to be done to
give kids a chance and we're gonna do
that under my proposal
look we're gonna reinstate the policies
push doing our administration to finish
the work of desegregating our schools
because we have a national interest in
creating diverse school bodies that's
what I believe we have to make sure that
we have that we're moving closer to the
idea of America's founding you know we
all learn in school we hold these two
self-evident that all men and women are
created equal
are we the people we've never lived up
to that we've never lived up to that
this is the 400th anniversary of the
first African American being brought to
the shores of the United States enslaved
that's the original sin of this nation
but we've never walked away from it
either
we've never walked away from the
expectation all of you in this room have
never walked away from it and look
there's only one president I know that's
actually deliberately walked away from
it and that is Donald Trump not a joke
think about this I don't know about you
Jess but I never thought that after all
the progress of the made I'd see people
marching out of fields carrying torches
contorted faces anger and hate
accompanied by white supremacists of the
Ku Klux Klan met by decent honorable
people who said we're note we don't hate
here and what happened clash ensued a
young woman who died and
he said when asked about he said quote
no presidents ever said this there are
very fine people in both groups he's yet
to apologize or criticize I criticize
the Ku Klux kind of the white
supremacists look we have a president
promotes hate and division has
encouraged the poison of white supremacy
our children are watching Barack was a
president our kids not only could but
did look up to look what presidents say
matters it matters and by the way when
we stay silent
our silence is complicity that's a learn
from my dad
your silence is complicity you know I
promise you if I get elected president I
will be a president stands against
racism the forces of inclusion and
intolerance everywhere in our society
and our institutions and our voting
booths and in our hearts it matters what
we say and since write a labor luncheon
is important to stand by and start by
recognizing black Hispanic Asian
American workers and Native American
workers and the communities of color all
across the nation that have driven and
strengthened the labor movement from his
beginnings as you spoke about mr.
president a moment ago from the Atlanta
washroom strike and washerwoman striking
in 1882 the delano grape strike and
boycott in 1990 in the 1960s from bill
Lucy and Byard Ruston Chicago's own Abby
wide and Jacqueline Vaughan black and
brown power have always been an integral
part of fighting for the right to
organize demanding equal pay fair
treatment basic workers protector as my
dad would say some dignity taking on the
fight of all workers from farmworkers to
domestic workers to tearing down
systemic racism along the way we owe
them we owe them big we owe you
and if I'm elected president I want you
to know labour will have an absolute
full partner in the White House and I
think labor knows that for me folks
a lots changed very badly since they're
out of office here and this president
and some members of the corporate
community believe that I want to make it
clear to Wall Street did not build
America stock brokers and hedge fund
managers did not build this country you
built this country the great American
middle class the unions built the middle
class that's why it exists we need to
rebuild it but this time we have to
bring everybody along no matter the race
their gender their ethnicity their
religion who they love where they live
or where they have a disability you know
my dad used to have an expression he
said Joey had jobs about a lot more than
a paycheck and he meant it when he had
to leave Scranton to go find work he
said Joey it's about your dignity it's
about respecting the community it's
about being able to look your child in
the eye and say honey it's going to be
okay and meaning to few people has been
referenced today too few people think
they can say that anymore a vast
majority for the first time in about 80
years the vast majority of middle-class
people are shrinking they no longer
believe their children will have the
responsibility mr. president you talked
about how your dad persisted and changed
things they don't think they're and the
today's corporate culture and this
administration they don't care about
your dignity instead of investing back
in their workers and record profits
record profits instead of investing back
in research and development to create
more opportunities corporate profits are
going to pay dividends to shareholders
and blockbuster executive compensation
ladies and gentlemen they're squeezing
the life out of workers today and by the
way and making it harder to meet very
basic needs stripping you of your
personal dignity along the way you know
there's long been a war on labor unions
as pointed out today mr. chair
y'all are coming back but here's the
deal there's been another war going on
that hadn't been noticed very much on
the ability of individuals to be able to
bargain further self-worth 40 percent of
workers today have to sign a non-compete
agreement now it's one thing you have
access to secrets of a great technical
organization your sign I won't compete
one thing you've ever business I'm going
to sell it but I'm not gonna blow up
next door when I sell it to you but a
significant portion these people are
hourly workers up until I started
hollering about this if you work for
Jimmy John's you had to sign a
non-compete agreement so you wouldn't
walk across town and try to get ten
cents more from McDonald's
what's this all about it's only one
purpose is to hold down the ability of
individuals even to bargain for their
own self-worth is to keep wages low and
it's wrong too many companies today
classify their workers as managers when
Labour fought to make sure that if
you're an hourly worker you got to be
had to be paid overtime what do they do
if you're above the person stacking
spaghetti cans on top of a shelf in a
supermarket but you control the person
who runs the forklift to bring it out
they say you're now a manager ladies and
gentlemen it costs more than 4 million
hourly workers 1.2 billion dollars last
year and where'd it go we went back in
the pocket of corporate America back
into so-called the job creators since
when since when the auto workers in my
state have made all those automobiles
that are gone they're gone now since
when were they not job creators today
the only people mr. chairman they think
are job creators are stockholders it's
ridiculous and look speaking overtime it
is long past time we have a $15 federal
minimum wage long past time
folks no it really is so we're getting
it done around the country folks
we needed a book we need to build an
economy that rewards work not just wages
not just well wages have to be rewarded
wages you realize that people who are
multimillionaires of play only capital
gains they pit a lower tax rate than any
of you all do look if I'm elected
president I will immediately repeal the
tax cuts for the super wealthy in this
Trump's administration and you know we
have 1.6 trillion dollars in loopholes
that exist in the law now 1.6 trillion
dollars you can't justify the vast
majority of that and so folks look what
I'm gonna do is use the money to invest
in America's future there's an
incredibly long list of policies I don't
have time nor do you have an inclination
listening to me go through but let me
tell you something we need an inclusive
economy from better access to capital
for blacktone small businesses to
reducing the decline in black
homeownership to making sure homes in
black communities are valued fairly you
realize the same home I know you do same
home and a predominantly black
neighborhood the same exact home and one
in the overwhelming white neighborhood
in the black neighborhood it's its value
that's significantly less limiting your
ability to borrow against those living
in your ability to do much about it and
guess what you pay a higher insurance
rate to for it even though it's less
look we need to reform the criminal
justice to make sure black mothers feel
confident when they send their child
their son out on the street it's going
to be safe we've got to recognize we got
to recognize that kid wearing the hoodie
may very well be the next poet laureate
and not a gangbanger ladies and
gentlemen there are too many black men
and I might add women in prison and we
started this too had a problem in our
administration we need to pass and this
met with Bobby Scott you know Bobby well
congresswoman just met with Bobby Scott
from Virginia his safe Justice Act it
needs to be passed but he
we need to do more no more Amanda no
more minimum mandatory prison sentence
period the end of private prisons
prisons is Brock and I talked about
funding original I wrote drug courts at
least four hundred billion dot four
hundred million dollars your bail reform
no one should be in bail because they
don't in jail because none of the money
to pay their bail no juveniles in adult
prisons mandatory treatment not jail for
those who are affected by and struggling
with addiction it makes no sense to put
people in jail put them in treatment and
keep them there while they are going
through treatment decriminalize
marijuana automatically expunge
marijuana convictions look folks for
finally 15 years and the crack powder
cocaine disparity so it's one to one no
different to many african-americans in
put in jail for it look and prisons but
I don't get and we just got to make the
case if you make it to ordinary people
they figure it out in prison you should
receive an education not how to be a
better criminal but you should learn how
to read and write
there should be job programs in there we
should be training people we should be
training them there's automatic
restoration of the rights once they
their sentence is served including all
rights to go to school Pell grants not
only right to vote not only a right to
participate but yet it's always it's
overwhelming the interest in the United
States of America and every citizen
black or white or Hispanic that you
re-educate people give them a chance
folks
look we can do all these things and so
much more we have to start by uniting
the country I know I get criticized for
saying we can unite the country ladies
and gentlemen I refuse to accept the
status quo the status called this
miserable ugly politics we have today
guarantees will continue to do the same
guarantees it we can't do it and we can
do without ever compromising on our
principle you know I know how
the labor leaders movement has moved for
decades that's how we're gonna win in
2020 and we're gonna win together when
we defeat Donald Trump
folks I've never been more optimistic
about America's future and I mean it
I needed you know there's a excuse me
for quoting an Irish poet my kid my
colleagues always kidding me the guy
named Seamus Heaney wrote a poem called
accurate Roy about the suppression of
Catholics in Ireland he wrote a poem and
he said we're taught never to hope on
this side of the grave but then once in
a lifetime that longed for tidal wave of
justice rises up and hope and history
when folks we're in a position now where
the American people have seen the very
dark side of America every generation is
saying enough we have a chance a real
chance we have a chance we stand up
remember who we are this is the United
States of America there's nothing we've
not been able to do if we're united in
it you know all those lines everybody
remembers from John Kennedy's speeches
about going to the moon he said this is
a challenge and willing unwilling this
is a challenge we are willing to accept
but the line I love boast he said we are
willing unwilling to postpone we're
unwilling to postpone I am unwilling to
postpone any longer to be deal with the
incredible opportunities we have so
ladies and gentlemen we have to remember
who we are pick our heads up work
together and god bless you all and may
God protect our troops
Vice President Joe Biden we are not done
yet how many of you are hungry Reverend
Marvin hunter if you could come to the
stage to give grace bless the food there
is so much more to this program so